olá boa noite a todos
eu vim aqui hoje contar uma história e
esta é uma história começa no vídeo
em setembro de 2004 estava eu até me em
casa quando encontrei vários atos como
este a porta da loja da plataforma a
forma criada pelo conteúdo chamou a
atenção e foi desligado
não sei se lembram que na altura os
telemóveis eram vendidos dentro destas
caixas transparentes acrílicas e quase
enquanto compravam os telemóveis quase
ninguém levava para casa e por isso elas
não estavam à porta das lojas no final
do dia eu achei interessante e um banho
dos sacos para casa
nessa altura eu tinha terminado uma
pós-graduação em vida artística para a
arquitetura eo meu trabalho consistia na
exploração do visível e invisível na
definição daquilo que vemos com o espaço
público e espaço privado e precisava
contar a história por trás da história a
história por trás de um momento para
isso trabalhava vidro manipulando o a
luz artificial e utilizava figuras
humanas e personagens
comecei a brincar com os cubos que tenha
trazido para casa
juntar e as minhas fotografias
panorâmicas e com influência no trabalho
tem vindo a desenvolver até que como
vidro no chão a primeira história que se
chamava um dia na praia
aqui a história das personagens é apenas
insinuava através da forma como estas
estão colocadas no palco e também pela
sua linguagem corporal
neste segundo exemplo os personagens
falam conosco e conta-nos através de
balões de fala os seus problemas daqui o
tema era o êxodo rural e esta fotografia
é uma paisagem alentejana uma história
muito diferente no estilo de um episódio
de uma investigação criminal
os principais suspeitos são sim
das profissão duvidosa estão a ser
interrogados nunca o trabalho já vimos
até que a inspiração para as minhas
histórias podia surgir de um momento do
cotidiano
poderia ser uma sátira convênios no
canto superior direito através do
pensamento de uma noiva no dia do
casamento mas poderia surgir também de
um filme e um livro ou seja apenas um
assunto mais ou menos sério que me impus
a explorar como sempre acontece neste
caso a família e os amigos foram os
primeiros que foram seus primeiros
clientes incentivaram e fui bater à
porta das principais lojas de design e
passaram algumas destas peças entre
outras
estará à venda na alma lusa no nosso
design e na música aqui no porto
e foi exatamente a mova passado alguns
meses no desafio a ser uma das designers
está é a serem apresentadas por isso
vamos eu ganho fia para possivelmente no
futuro terem suas peças à venda na loja
do museu para este projeto
criei a série do teatro é que as várias
peças são baseadas em diferentes obras
de literatura e teatro incorporar e
neste caso um novo completo para guardar
cds cartas de amor livros documentos
entre outras coisas aqui foi quando eu
gosto de chamar esta história do do lixo
para o museu é uma espécie de garoto
ainda se existisse um mundo de taxas
acrílicas marginalizados
embora as meninas ainda sobre esta série
embora as minhas personagens fossem
baseadas nestas obras eram um bocadinho
suspeitas
neste caso montar é um dom quixote e
jovem atleta é uma donzela em apuros
mais tarde fui novamente contactada pelo
museu rainha sofia
inaugurar uma retrospectiva sobre a
artista paula rego e pediram para fazer
uma peça baseada na sua vida e obra
sendo paula rego uma exímia contadora de
histórias e deixando sempre espaço uma
segunda interpretação das suas obras
tentarei transmitir a ideia várias
histórias estavam a ser contadas ao
mesmo tempo através dos transferências e
claro estamos a falar paula rego não
podiam deixar de existir pessoas com
cabeças de animais e vice versa
esta esta parceria com o museu reina
sofia fez com que fosse entrevistada
para a revista publica chamaram ao
artigo candeeiros com histórias lá
dentro
achei o nome perfeito numa tradução
livre surgiu oficialmente à anp
histórias continue ao longo dos anos a
trabalhar nas minhas histórias e todo o
processo é muito artesanal comigo a
cortar a colar ao fechar a elektro ficar
a mim e as peças e todo esse processo
ainda bastante artesanal
eu devo dizer também que nesta altura já
tinha uma forma considerável junto da
volta à forma como a menina corre o
bicho ao final do dia e assim passar dos
anos fui novamente compactado museu
rainha sofia para na mesma perspectiva
da elaboração de peças sobre os artistas
que iriam estará em exposição no museu
crê peça sobre a ue quer o at
mais tarde sobre anthony montadas e
ainda sobre o próprio uns errinhos fia e
sobre os seus paulo podem ver a lei
orgânica em grande plano
seguiu-se a fundação mato com a
exposição sobre está louca
aqui estava partilhar com vocês que isto
esta é um dos grandes prazeres do meu
trabalho
quero estar constantemente a aprofundar
ea estudar e pesquisar diferentes temas
mas vontade y logan depois de feita a
pesquisa é realizada em duas peças esta
inspirada nos movimentos e cores
africanas em que o próprio ys inspirava
nesta segunda peça o próprio é uma
personagem que parece estar a observar o
seu mundo e tudo o que conquistou
é que uma outra parceria desta vez com a
fundação de israel buscou ser lindíssimo
jardins idealizando um dia perfeito
estamos agora em 2012 quando uma e marés
para participar na capital européia da
cultura
isto vai assinar mais uma vez estou aos
seus habitantes as suas grandes e
pequenas histórias e contará idéias
peças estiveram em exposição numa
galeria temporária da cidade
aqui temos alguns exemplos das peças que
criei sobre guimarães esta participação
da capital europeia da cultura trouxe
alguma visibilidade além de histórias
mas eu estava agora com um grande
problema
estas caixas estavam a começar a ser
descontinuada serão cada vez mais
difíceis de arranjar descobrir o
fabrican descobrir o quanto pode custar
um monte e descobri também que para
reaproveitar o molde já existia em
fábrica prestes cubos quem é que ter
autorização da plataforma e aqui com o
som longo e penoso caminho de miles
proibidos cartas reuniões para conseguir
o tal então de java
estamos já há autorização mais uma vez a
família e os amigos foram incansáveis e
com a sua preciosa ajuda que aproveito
para agradecer aos que a autorização e e
conseguir principalmente continuar a
trabalhar e assim fiz sempre fica aí o
processo
procurei ajuda externa e até hoje
continuo
a trabalhar nas minhas histórias renda
criar candeeiros com histórias lá dentro
para terminar
entretanto não para terminar só falta
mais uma uma exposição ao episódio teve
recentemente participou recentemente no
o pam dae délcio factor em lisboa e
estas são algumas das peças novas peças
criadas para essa exposição baseada no
méxico as fotografias são sempre
fotografias tiradas por mim e pós
adaptadas às histórias que quero contar
aqui temos o terreiro do paço eo tema é
um pastor para terminar
agora sim estava partilhar com vocês
duas mensagens relacionadas com a
história que os que ainda estava a
contar que são a primeira a importância
de ser um dos curiosos
nunca sabemos o que vamos encontrar e de
que forma é que o que descobriremos no
pódio nos podem levar uma grande
aventura os variados em alguns gols ou
mesmo dar o nosso curso profissional e
quando falo aqui de curiosidade falta
aquela curiosidade típica da infância
aquela curiosidade nos leva a refletir o
lixo às duas da manhã ou por último
estava também nos dizer que numa altura
em que se fala tanto é que temos que
pensar outside the box por vezes
pensamos em sair do box também pode ser
muito certo
obrigada
[Aplausos]